[Music]
hey why is such turmoil in your mind
miss Thailand allow me to ease your pain
[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 19 video the funny
thing about this week's episode is that
it was almost like Captain colt or
citizen cold we should say because he's
from Earth X trying to get Barry to cry
from the entire episode but I almost
forgot that black siren or siren X as
they call her from Earth X was also
going to guess star so it was really fun
to throw her into the mix too and she
showed off a whole bunch of powers that
we've never seen her used before but if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
obviously there's only a couple more
weeks left before we finally get all the
answers about coffee shop girl about
what's gonna be happening with season 5
usually it's like the last two or three
episodes where they tee up some big
concept that they're gonna pay off in
season five aside from all the coffee
shop girl future speed for simple stuff
but top 10 WTF comic book Easter eggs
starting with number 10 we find out what
happened to Harrison wells
when he overloaded on dark matter he's
basically getting Dumber by the minute
but the way that Cisco explains it and
it's also part of the killer frost
storyline is that they leave this little
seed of hope that they can reverse some
of the damage like there's a seed of
killer frost inside Caitlin's DNA so
they can tease that back out probably
before the end of the season I don't
expect them to completely reverse all
the damage that happened but it lets you
know that there's something for them to
do between seasons so like this is
something that they can start now like
oh you know here's a little bit of
killer frost
maybe we can perfect this but it's an
interesting twist on the idea of how
killer frost is integrated with her
personality and her DNA like used to be
that dark matter was a necessary
component of that but the dark matter
was removed from her so we'll see what
their scientific explanation is for how
killer frost can still exist within her
and she can still manifest those powers
but it sounds like the setup for another
slightly different version of killer
frost during season 5 so we might not
fully get to see that till next season
but number 9 the thinker stops dosing
his wife with the weeper tears like oh
you're happy so I'm not going to give
you this drug
it's gonna make you do what I want you
to do so it's just laying the seeds for
her to slowly start figuring out what's
going on and start to turn against him
but part of the funny thing with the
thinker's storyline I mean
unintentionally funny maybe they wanted
you to laugh at it was the way that he
was so adamant that they not feel any
emotion like you very clearly see where
they're going with this his wife wants
to do happy married couples stuff but
all he cares about is the Enlightenment
so this is just the beginning of the end
for their alliance he kind of slipped it
in too but he also made it sound like he
was going to be taking another Medes
powers and Caitlin also referenced him
not going after Barry earlier in the
season huh you know he didn't want
Barry's powers the thinker says that
because of Ralph's powers he can hold
even more metahuman DNA inside him
meaning that he can steal the powers of
someone else so it sounds like they're
leaving themselves a door maybe for him
to try and take Barry's powers and to
get this comic book panel you know we
are the flash and paying it off in that
WTF way number eight welcome back Tracy
brand even though she didn't appear in
the episode this is the first time that
I think that they've referenced her in a
while
maybe at the very beginning of the
season when they were explaining where
Julian went like Julian went back to
Europe
so that's where he's been Tracy went off
to do her own stuff now we know that she
has a lab in Keystone City where she's
just conducting her own experiments and
that's where they stashed the fallout
character after episode 10 but who knows
if she'll ever come back they reference
Argus during the episode so there's more
low-level crossover with all the other
shows in this larger universe sometimes
I wish the shows would lean on each
other a little bit more in that way even
if you can't have all the actors from
the other shows crossing over physically
like I think they included some more
arrow references because you have siren
X and they did make some jokes about all
the different versions of the canary
that we've had so far like there was
Sarah then she died became the white
canary and Cisco's like I get it I get
it it's complicated but number seven
welcome back citizen cold and welcome
siren X I think this is the first time
we've seen her I don't remember her from
the crossover but they explained that
she's like the last remaining person
from the reich's men's team which is
basically like dark arrows whole squad
but the really funny thing about this
though is that citizen cult kind of
takes a dig at her when he says that she
really loved dark arrow but it was
unrequited so there's just a reference
to all the drama but
those characters on the arrow TV show
but always love Wentworth Miller they
gave him all kinds of crazy flash puns
you can't outrun grief berry sorry if
that was a pun I mean it's the flash you
have to have a flash pun every once in a
while number six citizen cold keeps
trying to get Barry to cry so they kind
of did this on legends of tomorrow with
the exact same version of the character
right after the crossover so remember
how Martin Stein died during the
crossover so Leo snart citizen cold went
on the Waverider and did sort of like
little therapy sessions with all the
characters like even jacks he used this
weird little puppet it was the most
bizarre thing ever but it was just a way
for the show to honor this really big
character that was leaving like he meant
so much to us so this is citizen Cole
doing the exact same thing with Barry's
character like getting him to process
his grief and he also gets to do the
same thing with Caitlin - look you
learned that Caitlin really does miss
killer frost so even after our last
week's episode there were a couple
moments with Caitlin where she seemed
kind of sad
like they teed it up with the notes like
oh these funny notes like she was
friends with killer frost now so her
losing that part of herself was gonna be
this big wound that she would have to
learn to heal the really weird thing
about siren x though is that how she can
use her sonar ability to listen to what
they're saying almost like half a city
away like she's way off in Keystone City
almost listening to them inside STAR
Labs so you're like wait a minute has
black siren on our earth been able to do
this the whole time how come we haven't
seen her use this ability because they
even say that her powers are similar to
that of black siren but number five
Barry versus DeVoe form route for the
first time since Ralph died this is
actually one of my favorite scenes
because it's DeVoe taunting Barry he
even uses Ralph's voice to try and get a
rise out of him and Barry just freezes
the funny thing though too was a way to
vote reacted to that like as part of
this whole arc where the thinker is an
emotional dummy - it just doesn't read
emotion on other people he doesn't
understand Barry's grief but I love the
way that siren X you know number 4
hijacks the thinkers hijacking of
Fallout mostly out of spite the reason
she's there is because she's in grief
and this is the way she's acting out
because she cared about all of her
Reich's Minh even though they're all
Nazis and they're all terrible people
number 3 Barry finally gets his
together
saves the day then goes and promptly
starts weeping in his old lab remember
we haven't been here since he was put on
leave because of the whole stalking
incident with the thinker and the
thinker's wife earlier this season
that'll probably get rolled back at the
end because of what's going on with the
thinker's wife right now I think if
anybody walks away from their team this
season it's the thinker's wife it sounds
like the thinker is either down for the
count or the find a way to depower him
so that his original body will just
start to degenerate and he'll eventually
die but it was a great action scene they
did a great job of building tension and
it was fun to see them tag-team fall out
with their cold guns like oh yeah that's
right we have two different versions of
the cold gun now so I'm guessing that
Caitlyn is probably just gonna be using
that until she gets her powers back
funny enough though I wonder if they
plan to always take her powers away
because remember way back during Episode
one she was using captain colds gun they
even put it in the first trailer they
released a Comic Con so it was almost
like they were foreshadowing this
version of Caitlyn that early in the
season even though at that time she was
suppressing her abilities but number two
Davos wife finally seems like she's
starting to plot against him but
remember like she had to feign happiness
so that he wouldn't give her the weeper
tears maybe now behind the scenes while
they continued to construct the
Enlightenment device she tries to start
sabotaging things by plotting with team
flash but there has to be some moment
where she formally comes to them for
help she's had a lot of her scenes with
Iris in the past so I'm wondering if
maybe it's iris that brokers that deal
so just remains to be seen what it is
that causes her to finally go and try to
get help from them so number one of
course citizen cold goes back to Earth X
he's still getting married to the Ray
but they give him one of those portal
devices that they gave to Supergirl
after her first crossover so that he can
come back anytime that he wants like
they even give him Captain colds jacket
so it's almost like we're bringing back
Captain cold to the flash only
technically it's citizen cold from Earth
X but he is pretty much the same
character just a little bit nicer and a
little bit quicker on the draw when it
comes to puns I haven't been a huge fan
of the therapy sessions this season but
I understand why they brought it back
for this episode I mean it kind of
worked within the context but I just
like to see them get rid of that for
season five we're probably all on the
same page that Barry's best therapy
sessions in the
episode were with citizen coals so why
not just continue that theme if you're
gonna do stuff like this just have him
have that moment with one of the other
team members but let me know in the
comments what was your favorite part of
the episode and what do you think is
gonna cause Davos wife to finally come
to team flash and form a plan to stop
the thinker's enlightenment but like
next week's episode seems like we're
gonna get to see what the actual device
looks like if you're not sure what was
going on with thinker and fallout at the
end of the episode either he was plugged
in to that Tahiti device in Argus it's
where he wants fallout to be so that he
can use his abilities to juice up his
enlightenment device if you guys didn't
see I just posted my non-spoilery
infinity war review no worries no
spoilers click here for that and you can
click here for more new flash I'll post
a trailer video tomorrow morning thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight